[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos y amigas de visual
político como ocurre cada principio de
año transparente internacional ha
publicado su célebre ranking con los
países más y menos corruptos del planeta
hablamos como ya os hemos dicho en
alguna que otra ocasión del que es
considerado como el rolls-royce de los
rankings de corrupción y en este caso
sus resultados son muy similares a los
del pasado año lógicamente los sistemas
corruptos pues no se transforman de la
noche a la mañana y menos aún cuando hay
una pandemia en marcha que capta toda la
atención pública por este motivo y como
ya tenemos un vídeo con los resultados
del año pasado que muchos estoy seguro
ya habéis visto lo que vamos a hacer en
esta ocasión no sólo de echar un vistazo
al ranking sino también ver claramente
cómo la corrupción puede destruir por
completo un país y como ante una
catástrofe una pandemia sus resultados
pueden ser aún más dolorosos en este
vídeo vamos a ver con ejemplos concretos
como algunos desaprensivos han hecho del
coronavirus una oportunidad de oro para
saquear las arcas públicas pero queridos
amigos empecemos por el principio
estos son los países que se llevan el
premio los países más y menos corruptos
de todo el planeta alguna apuesta pues
atentos
[Música]
la corrupción en el mundo del 2020 tal y
como ya os contamos el pasado año en
cuestiones de corrupción queda mucho por
hacer y tenemos pocos motivos para sacar
pecho más de dos terceras partes de los
países suspenden flagrantemente en este
ranking yo creo que una buena prueba de
todo esto lo podemos encontrar en los
propios comentarios de visual politics y
en los comentarios de visual política
donde muchos de vosotros os pegáis
recurrentemente por ver qué país es el
más corrupto de todos el mío no no el
tuyo no el mío qué dices más que el mío
no en fin pues bien según transparente
internacional los cinco países más
corruptos del planeta en 2020 fueron los
siguientes en quinta posición no podía
faltar venezuela que ya está cerca muy
cerquita de darle al gobierno
bolivariano la posibilidad de
convertirse en algo en el número uno
mundial aunque sea por sobornos coimas y
corruptelas de todo tipo jet por encima
de venezuela estaría en yemen siria
somalia y por último sudan del sur el
campeón mundial de corrupción según
transparencia internacional luego por el
lado opuesto los países más limpios del
mundo serían estos seis empatados con 85
puntos suiza suecia singapur y field
y ligeramente por encima de ellos
empatados en primera posición
dinamarca y nueva zelanda seguro que no
te sorprende y amigos si lo vemos por
regiones el ranking quedaría tal que así
[Música]
nueva zelanda singapur y australia
serían los tres países más limpios de
asia-pacífico y por contra camboya
afganistán y corea del norte los más
corruptos en asia central y el antiguo
espacio soviético prácticamente todos
los países obtienen unas puntuaciones
muy malas pero aún así encontramos
ejemplos mejores ejemplos peores georgia
armenia y bielorrusia son los tres
países menos corruptos a pesar de que
tan solo georgia supera los 50 puntos
que sería algo así como el aprobado en
corrupción y el galardón a los tres
peores se lo llevan los tan uzbekistán
türkmenistán y tayikistán a que amigos
la corrupción debe ser casi casi algo
típico característico según parece poco
menos que tradicional
vamos que casi podemos decir que si los
visitas si no pagas un buen soborno pues
oye te pierdes la experiencia local pero
sigamos en oriente medio y el norte de
áfrica de esta acampada bien emiratos y
qatar mientras que siria yemen y libia
que son prácticamente tres estados
fallidos se llevan la peor parte
luego en el áfrica sub-sahariana y a
pesar de lo que podríamos pensar
encontramos algunas buenas noticias al
menos son cinco los países que aprueban
las seycheles botsuana caboverde
mauricio del que por cierto nos hace muy
poquito y ruanda la peor parte se la
llevan sudán somalia y sudán del sur por
su parte europa es con mucha diferencia
de la región que mejor parada sale en
cabeza en el ranking dinamarca finlandia
y suecia y lo cierran por abajo
hungría rumanía y bulgaria y por ultimo
américa con canadá uruguay y eeuu en lo
alto del ranking por debajo bueno aquí
amigos la mala noticia es que
exceptuando uruguay chile costa rica y
alguna que otra pequeña isla del caribe
todos los restantes países
latinoamericanos suspenden rotundamente
mucha política muchos planes y muchas
promesas pero a la hora de la verdad
suspenso ahora bien más allá de este
recorrido geográfico que ni we live o la
pregunta la gran pregunta que podemos
hacernos es es tan grave todo esto de la
corrupción pueden realmente los sobres
las coimas los pagos encubiertos los
sobornos hundir un país pues queridos
amigos y amigas de visor político
bienvenidos a honduras
[Música]
devastado por la corrupción vale
honduras no es el peor país del mundo en
esta materia ni siquiera es el país
latinoamericano más corrupto según
transparente internacional nicaragua
haití y venezuela están por delante pero
ahora bien lo que sí es honduras es un
buen ejemplo de país que lleva años
empeorando en estos rankings y que en
2020 ha sufrido como pocos las
consecuencias de esta enorme erosión
institucional para que os hagáis una
idea aquí en este país la corrupción se
está transformando en un entramado tan
tóxico que lo está haciendo convertirse
en todo un estado fallido un país
hundido económicamente en el que la
violencia y los abusos políticos crecen
como la espuma un país amigos en el que
se calcula que la corrupción sería por
sí misma una de las principales
actividades económicas fijaos la
corrupción en honduras se traga el 12 5%
del pib el 12,5 por ciento del pib de
honduras del 2018 fue absorbido por la
corrupción en sus distintas formas según
un recuento presentado en tegucigalpa
por organizaciones de la red anti
corrupción hablamos de casi 3 mil
millones de dólares en el que se ha
convertido ya en uno de los países más
pobres de toda latinoamérica un país en
el que el 2020 no ha supuesto otra cosa
que tragedia dolor y día
de la corrupción y amigos cuando digo
vía libre a la corrupción lo digo
literalmente
fijaos el 2020 arrancó en honduras con
la decisión del presidente juan orlando
hernández de no renovar el mandato de
lamas y la misión de apoyo contra la
corrupción y la impunidad en honduras
que la organización de estados
américanos había desplegado en el país
un organismo creado en 2016 para
combatir la corrupción en honduras pues
bien desde 2016 está más y puso en
marcha 14 operaciones contra 133
personas incluida dos miembros del
congreso y altos funcionarios del
gobierno éste fue por ejemplo el caso de
la operación pandora una trama que
detectó como 38 altos responsables
políticos y funcionarios desviaban
millones de dólares de dólares
norteamericanos desde el presupuesto
destinado a la mejora de la agricultura
hasta sus bolsillos personales y también
enojó a los de los partidos políticos
pues bien el caso es que tras aprobar
durante los últimos cuatro años
diferentes medidas para imposibilitar o
al menos limitar en la práctica la
acción de la máx y finalmente el
presidente orlando decidió echarla del
país normal era una organización muy
incómoda para los corruptos pero amigos
eso ni siquiera es lo peor en 2020
también hemos visto algunos cambios
legales que entre otras cosas han dado
muchas facilidades y
cómo decirlo un trato legal mucho más
confortable para los corruptos si lo
habéis escuchado bien
durante el mes de julio del 2020 entró
en vigor un cambio del código penal- que
reduce las penas por tráfico de
narcóticos contrabando fraude contra la
administración pública o malversación de
caudales públicos entre otros delitos
incluso se contempla para los casos de
corrupción sustituir sentencias de
prisión por otras condenas menos
restrictivas cuando el acusado sea
condenado a menos de cinco años y
devuelva el dinero
vamos para entendernos que puedes formar
de una trama corrupta y si te pillan
bueno devolviendo solo lo que te han
pillado pues incluso te puedes liberar
de la cárcel y vuelta a empezar y ahí no
termina todo aun ahí más se deja de lado
la responsabilidad penal de las personas
jurídicas y sabemos cómo funcionan
ciertas empresas en honduras vemos
cualquier cantidad de empresas que
entablan relaciones con el estado ya no
tener responsabilidad penal deja mucho
que desear
rigoberto reyes ha rogado hondureño al
mismo tiempo esta reforma del código
penal ha limitado también la capacidad
de los medios de comunicación para
destapar casos de corrupción claro
encaja verdad pues amigos estamos
hablando de una reforma que ya está en
vigor muchos de los congresistas que la
aprobaron por cierto tenían cuentas
pendientes con la justicia
casualidad vosotros mismos pero que el
mismo presidente haya sido culpado por
fiscales federales de los eeuu de haber
recibido dinero del narcotráfico para
promover su carrera política pues qué
queréis que os diga da la sensación de
que tampoco es una coincidencia
todo esto está vinculado una estrategia
un proceso sistemático que viene del
congreso y el ejecutivo que han
debilitado las instituciones ya débiles
que persiguen los delitos especialmente
la corrupción y el tráfico de drogas
crime y es que estamos hablando de
honduras un país donde prácticamente
todo parece que está contagiado de
corrección por ejemplo un estudio sobre
los empleados públicos mostró que estos
mismos trabajadores consideraban que las
dos características las dos
características más importantes para
lograr un empleo del gobierno eran estar
afiliados al partido político que
estuviera en el poder y conocer a las
personas adecuadas fijaos de hecho es
conocido que entre los más de 220.000
burócratas que tiene el gobierno
hondureño muchos han sido colocados a
dedo por los políticos desde luego no me
negaréis como estrategia para ganarse el
apoyo de los funcionarios pues no está
nada mal
amigos la corrupción empieza estar tan
extendida que el mismísimo partido
gobernante el partido nacional parece
haber hecho de esta actividad una de sus
banderas políticas me refiero a que
ejercen la corrupción no a que luchan
contra ella incluso se sospecha o mejor
dicho prácticamente se da por hecho se
sabe se conoce que tienen lazos con
grupos de narcotraficantes
[Música]
por ejemplo fabio lobo el hijo del ex
presidente está cumpliendo una pena de
24 años luego el mismísimo hermano del
presidente ha sido declarado por un
tribunal de nueva yor culpable de varios
cargos incluida la conspiración para
importar eeuu polvitos blancos y no
precisamente azúcar por su parte el
presidente del congreso mauricio oliva
también ha tenido vínculos con grupos de
narcos y el alcalde de tegucigalpa y
candidato presidencial nadie asegura
tiene acusaciones de corrupción
y el presidente bueno el presidente es
que ya juega en otra revisión como os
decía antes en un documento oficial el
día 8 de enero los propios fiscales
federales de los eeuu señalaron
directamente al presidente hondureño por
vínculos con narcos e incluso le
acusaron de haber recibido dinero a
cambio de comprometerse a proteger a
dichos narcos y prestarles ojo apoyo
militar para facilitar sus actividades y
ojo que hablamos de un tipo que financió
la campaña política que le llevó al
poder con una trama de corrupción que
saqueo 300 millones de dólares del
instituto hondureño de la seguridad
social
en uno de los países más pobres de
latinoamérica las pruebas reunidas por
el departamento de justicia de eeuu en
este y otros casos dejan pocas dudas de
que los políticos más influyentes de
honduras incluido el presidente un
importante aliado de washington reciben
millones de dólares de los traficantes
para financiar campañas y consolidar su
poder insightcrime el caso amigos es que
2020 fue un año que nos mostró como
nunca antes las implicaciones que la
corrupción puede llegar a tener para un
país pensáis que exagero pues fijaos
tragedias y violencia
durante el año 2020 de honduras no sólo
se enfrentó al coronavirus sino también
a dos huracanes devastadores dos
huracanes que dejaron a miles de
hondureños sin casa y a cientos de miles
sin acceso a servicios básicos una
acumulación de desastres que sin embargo
ojo algunos han convertido en un enorme
negocio pero queréis algún ejemplo
concreto pues fijaos tras desatarse la
pandemia del sars coronavirus 2 en marzo
del 2020 el gobierno le encargó a marco
bográn entonces director ejecutivo del
organismo inversión estratégica de
honduras la compra de siete hospitales
de campaña para dotar a la lucha contra
la cob it con 450 camas suena bien
verdad pues espera un momento porque la
operación fue rocambolesca
marc como gran le encargó una empresa
que tenía su domicilio en un buzón de
una oficina de ups en orlando florida la
compra de estos siete hospitales por
casi 50 millones de dólares que podéis
creerme que para honduras supone mucho
dinero pues bien esos más de 47 millones
que se pagaron sin ni siquiera firmar un
contrato en condiciones suponen entre 12
y 16 millones de dólares por encima del
precio habitual de mercado y eso no es
todo porque a pesar de ser supuestamente
una operación urgente los dos primeros
hospitales de campaña tardaron más de
cuatro meses en llegar al país y cuando
lo hicieron la sorpresa fue mayúscula
parecían de segunda mano mostraban daños
y no contaban con equipamiento para
enfrentarse al hobbit
[Música]
es decir que se compraron hospitales
equipados para cuidados intensivos a
precio de oro y encima lo que se recibió
pues fueron poco más que tiendas de
campaña de segunda mano muchos meses más
tarde por cierto el empresario que
vendió estos hospitales axel lópez es un
tipo que publicó un libro donde entre
otras cosas contaba cómo hacer negocios
en la tan consejos entre los que incluía
el pago de sobornos nada más que añadir
señoría pero ojo que no fue un caso
aislado
[Música]
varias organizaciones han detectado
otros contratos inflados para la
adquisición de equipos de bioseguridad
como por ejemplo ventiladores y máscaras
equipos que en algunos casos ni siquiera
se han entregado evidentemente hablamos
de conductas que no sólo han costado tu
dinero sino también vidas humanas pero
amigos y pensé que aquí termina todo
pues esta es otra vez muy equivocados la
corrupción generalizada y la erosión de
las instituciones también ha acelerado
otro proceso la conversión de honduras
en un narcoestado
y es que veréis si antes hablábamos de
las relaciones que se dan frecuentemente
entre la clase política y los grupos de
narcos ahora os puedo contar también
como la violencia se está dañando del
país o como incluso los cultivos de coca
comienzan a extenderse por toda la
geografía hondureña y si así así es como
dura se está caminando hacia su
conversión en un estado fallido amigos
esta es la historia de cómo la
corrupción está devorando este pequeño
país centroamericano pero llegados hasta
aquí turno para ti cómo se vive la
corrupción en tu país cómo piensas que
se podría vencer déjanos tu respuesta
aquí abajo en los comentarios y ya
sabéis si está y nuestra resulta
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like i suscribiros adiós al político
una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
joe juan orlando hernández voy a hacer
lo que tenga que hacer para recuperar la
paz y la tranquilidad de mi pueblo